[Music]
all right let's go to morgan and tyler
tx
what's up morgan
hi dr john how are you
um i'm good my heart is pounding right
now
hey you are you are in safe hands and by
safe hands they're definitely not mine
but kelly and james are driving so
you're good you're good
so what's
up okay so um i have taken a team of
people to romania in september hey real
quick real quick real quick morgan talk
directly into your phone there
okay is that better oh a thousand times
better great
okay um so we're taking a team to
romania in september uh to work with
ukrainian refugees and i was just
wondering how can i prepare our team
for the trauma stories that we're doing
here and how can we respond to those
stories as we you know hear them and
interact with those people i love this
question it's so good and it's
applicable both for people going in to
deal with
war zone refugees and it's also
important for how do you deal with your
middle school kids at home right so
great great question um talk about what
are y'all doing there you all going to
like be giving them food and shelter
what are y'all what work you all doing
uh that's a great question um our
host there i've been talking with her
about it and she was kind of explaining
like
we really don't know obviously what the
status of the war is going to be when we
go and what the needs are going to be
but she gave me an idea of what they're
doing now and they're delivering
supplies they're doing programs for
refugee children they're actually
delivering supplies into ukraine
um they're transporting refugees from
their border to wherever else they need
to go where their family members are so
that's kind of the general idea of what
we might be doing at the time but we
don't really know i love it okay cool so
i'm writing notes down to myself right
here
um and i'm gonna rattle them off at you
okay probably if you don't have
something to write with that's totally
fine you can go back and just listen to
this and we can even send you a clip um
it won't come out for a while and you
may be on the road already so we can
send you something but
um
here's a couple of entry point um things
to keep in your back pocket that would
be great for you to circle up your team
and meet with them how old is your team
going over
um
really all ages i've had some people uh
in high school interested of people in
their 40s okay all right
okay so here we go the first thing
that's important is
everybody has to go in with the idea
that we're going to be listeners not
fixers
very little somebody can bring over from
you know dallas texas to ukraine in the
in like you know what y'all should be
doing this
what you could really be
be providing them is a listening ear and
them getting very quickly
a group of people paid their own money
or a group of other people provided the
means for someone to travel over just to
sit with me
they crossed oceans just to be with me
during my darkest hour and there's it's
incredibly healing and so i would put
big number one
listen more talk less
right listen more talk less
um the second thing is i would start a
practice right now so as people are
deciding if they want to go they want to
be a part of this
part of them signing up and saying yes
they put their deposit in or whatever
i want you to have some sort of
journaling apparatus some sort of
journal for them that you're going to
hand them and say you start today okay
and here's why that's important they're
going to have to have some sort of
processing mechanism and i want them to
practice that a couple of weeks before
they head over there and this is going
to be where you as the supervisor or you
and like a group of team leaders are
going to really step into this gap here
but i want them to write at the end of
every day and i want you and your team
to spend an extra hour or two before you
all go to bed reading and responding to
these things
okay okay
something about being heard in the midst
of chaos is a gift to the human physique
like physical system it just
it lets you drop your shoulders somebody
hear what i'm seeing right and
you will also begin to see if one or two
of your
team members
if they're starting to rattle at the
seams right they're starting to kind of
untether a little bit and that's a great
way people will write things that they
won't say and it's easy when you're
doing this kind of work to um
you know rally a circle and be like all
right how's everybody well the folks who
are really struggling probably aren't
going to say anything
and so when you're writing it down they
will
another thing here um
stay off stay off stay off the news
be with be present where you're at and
here's another hard one along that same
line
if at all possible limit the number of
domestic them texting especially them
facetiming back home
y'all go over there be fully there one
of the this is a hypothesis of mine that
i'm still working through and i don't
even know how i would
sit down with a research group to figure
this out but
i've seen we've seen the rise in ptsd
we've seen the rise in just general
anxiety across the world and i go back
to
us our brains are not designed to live
stream war right we're designed to our
brains are designed to respond to
threats in our immediate ecosystem
and when i look at the rise of ptsd
among soldiers i have to wonder if one
of the great gifts is when they're
deployed they can still go watch their
kids little league game because their
spouses can facetime it right or they
can see their spouses in facetime they
don't have to they can digitally attend
birthday parties
but it also is asking the brain to do
something it's never it's not designed
to do which is to
go out on mission during the day and
then be a dad in the my living room 17
000 miles away at night
and i'm wondering if the toggle back and
forth is taxing on their mind i'm not
saying
if i'm a soldier and i'm deployed you're
doing right i'm going to facetime every
day i'm not going to miss those moments
but i have to wonder if there's some
sort of physiological consequence
downstream and similar here i want that
team if they sign up to go
this is not to facebook stuff and to
send instagram posts it's just to be
present to help hurting people so let's
like we may have a once a week we may
all get together and do facetime back
home
but i want everybody present okay
and then here's the last thing i would
tell you
um every single person on this trip will
come back different
they're to change and
often we really struggle and fight
change as it's happening to us
you can't sit with ukrainian refugees
and not experience
not have that secondary traumatic stress
not have some of that
that hatred and ugliness and evil and
pain and hurt rub off on you and it
hopefully they can bring those lessons
back but trying to fight that change is
gonna be hard so
you as the leader will be having
conversations about okay what does this
look like moving forward how are you
going to be different what change in the
world are you going to be a part of
now that you've experienced this and so
what we're doing is we're taking that
grief and we're quickly toggling it to
making meaning here right what what
changes in the world are you going to be
a part of
as a result of this not that was a cool
experience and we got to some cool ig
posts out of it and i'm going to go on a
college resume or i'm going to do a talk
on it at my local church no that's not
why we're doing this we're actually
going to sit with hurting people does
that make sense
yeah absolutely awesome those are just a
few a few tips um the big one is
my
i think i've talked about it on the show
whenever i would go to a scene um a
crisis scene and it was like gruesome
crisis scenes that were just a mess or
really really heavy ones
um whereas you know somebody had been
murdered and the families rallied up in
a circle and
my supervisor would always call and
check in with me and he would say what'd
you see
what's your body doing what'd you feel
what's next and he would just go through
these questions but i always remember
this 2 a.m 3 a.m he's calling checking
in so
i always appreciated that human
connection and
come to find out it's neurologically and
physiologically the right thing to do
also to reconnect each other other
people so make sure you all check in
with each other but thank you thank you
for going to love hurting people that's
really a gift what what what what
inspired you to do this
um so in
2018 my sister and i actually went to
jordan to work with syrian refugees
and um
when this opportunity came along and
just knew that that was something that
i felt like god had
kind of created that passion for me to
just go help those people in need so so
the things i just rattled off here
would that have applied to your
experience in in syria
oh absolutely yeah like i said uh then
when it comes back different i was like
uh yep
very cool well thank you for your heart
and thank you for being willing to go
love and just sit with people
and
usually i like people to enter into a
space with a mission like i'm going to
get people out of this burning building
i'm not just going to go hang around in
the building while it burns
i
i like them too if you're going to enter
into a crisis situation have an
objective
but i kind of like your heart here
we don't know what we're doing but we're
going to go sit with hurting people and
if they ask us to make eggs then we're
going to make eggs and if they ask to
sweep the floor we're going to sweep the
floor and ask us just to hold them and
hear their stories write their stories
down tell their stories on our return
trips that's what we're gonna do
that's a beautiful heart thank you so
much